what did you guys think of the halftime
show i liked it but i knew what it was
right it's just we're just it's just a
nostalgia play which is what so many of
these things are yeah every commercial
and even super bowl halftime show
[ __ ] bruce springsteen or tom petty
or whoever else they get it's always
nostalgic almost always guys yeah i
think the same thing i mean i'm watching
it being like oh i wish there was
younger acts on this yeah of course i
think kendrick was the only person that
like dropped an album within like five
years yeah eminem be dropping them [ __ ]
we don't care yeah i guess but like
dropping like you know a massive like
breakout album and so i was like it'd be
nicer to see like younger people but at
the same time i guess the viewership of
the super bowl and like the nfl in
general is probably
30 plus right so i'm like yeah i get why
they did it and i like that they'd put
all like the la legends that was fire
minus like eminem and 50. yeah
i [ __ ] loved it yeah like i loved it
it may be having to do i was in la
watching it and so they were going
[ __ ] nuts
yeah
like that energy in the room was [ __ ]
that was the most hype the stadium was
during the halfway [ __ ] losers but it
was cool to see snoop open up a super
bowl in l.a and hear california
snoop is incredible dude i think snoop
is underrated so good so crisp such a
good performer at this age with all that
[ __ ] potty smoke and so you're so
sharp like there's never been really
anybody
who is like snoop no who does who sounds
like him who even raps like him walks
like him who talks like he is his own
thing yeah and it's just so cool and i
think that because we see him as this
almost like um cartoon yeah that maybe
we don't appreciate that enough yeah
he's almost like shaq yeah i mean like
yeah he fills all these different
positions in like the world and yeah
he's able to like code switch so easily
but you also forget oh he's like a
legend in his own right at like what he
did yeah it's amazing like he code
switches while being him he doesn't
actually switch his code
he just fits in perfectly as him
wherever he is yeah yeah that yeah i
guess code switches isn't the right
thing but like he can play on a cartoon
like he can be in sesame street we're
totally okay with it and then he can be
up there throwing up the sea yeah yeah
you know talking cryptos crypt that and
so it's like
wow like for some reason we accept you
doing all things yes there's nothing
that you do that's inappropriate yeah
you can talk about wildlife we love it
yeah you can talk about a boxing match
you can be one of the commentators we
love it he was doing a show with martha
stewart and she was the one that went to
prison
that's crazy like not the affiliated
rapper like martha stewart yeah oh you
brought this up this is funny that uh
we're canceling all these comedians and
then you have a halftime show with a guy
who's on trial for murder a guy who
allegedly beat his wife
uh and then what was the other
accusations and then eminem has
literally said everything wrong possible
and these guys are part of the corporate
super bowl halftime show like
corporations are okay with these guys
and the only thing that they had a
problem with was eminem kneeling yeah
that was the thing they're like wait
buddy
what do you think about that
that [ __ ] was a little bit try hard
right like he's trying to get it back
bruh
he don't realize it just be a wild boy
yeah just be wild like you don't have to
do all the woke activisty [ __ ] like just
be you you are wild he's old enough that
we don't believe it anymore yeah he
survives on him he like outgrew the
stuff we loved most about him
interesting
he doesn't have the angst and [ __ ] yeah
yeah relapse was 15 years ago and that's
that's you're too old to relapse then
yeah now you're a [ __ ] grandfather
bruh stop it no relapse
yeah yeah i just felt forced man like he
hit it and he put his hand over it and i
was like what are you doing right now
like
he's just a little bit late
right it's just a little bit late that's
good yeah right like like when he was
taking shots at trump it was like yo
it's over yeah yeah like no i can't it's
over he's still he's still late he's
just detached it's a shame because he's
brilliant he's objectively brilliant
yeah but i guess with rap specifically
it matters so much what you're rapping
about or the feeling that you're like
exuding in your rap and right now that
feeling just feels a little bit late or
dated
you know like
i know the right thing to say is like oh
it's great you're standing up for
kaepernick's right to take a knee and
it's like
after kaepernick put out that netflix
thing bro
[Laughter]
game over bro like that [ __ ] was bad so
bad dude it was so was that not bad so
bad al can't admit it but it was so bad
you didn't even see it i didn't even
look at him i just knew he wouldn't say
a word you didn't see the netflix thing
where they compared the
they compared the nfl to slavery and it
was like a slave auction
you didn't see this
oh he just shits on his parents who
adopted him the whole [ __ ] movie stop
hating these guys man they try their
best well i don't think that they were
like measuring them and seeing what he
could do when they adopted it right like
they were making him run a 40. crawl
this 40.
right like i'm saying the whole movie
did you watch the thing no definitely
constantly just